il va faire très chaud aujourd'hui à los
angeles
mort c'est quoi le programme aujourd'hui
marc arazi
voilà
comme tous les jours
qu'est ce que vous faites dans ma
chambre
chasse aux vampires
pognon
la chasse aux vampires c'est un business
je tranche des gorges et j'encaisse
[Musique]
ça a changé depuis que tu t'es fait
jeter comme une merde du syndicat il
doit trouver 10 400 kw à ma femme et ma
fille vont partir en floride pour
changer n'y a qu'eux qui peuvent
allonger ce genre de thunes
son dossier est un joyeux bordel
[Musique]
au delà c'est un homme neuf une dernière
chance c'est votre dernière carte
voilà du tac
vettel
des vampires bien d'essayer de me tuer
et en plus c'est baisser dans mon plus
beau pantalon
se pisse dessus la première fois que
c'est vrai
non non moi non mais écoute toi
tu sais ce que je vois quand je vois un
vampire un gros paquet d'oseille
n'écoute pas ok rabat les
prêts à dégainer
[Musique]
les vampires si je pars me
c'est tout ce que des assassins
c'est pas hésitation dans ta tion de
révélation 1ère partie ça rien à voir
pourquoi tu connais par coeur les titres
de la saga twilight bugs et pourquoi tu
aimes pas révélation deuxième partie
c'est la conclusion idéale de toute la
saga twilight bienvenue dans le service
de jour pendant x ray
à tous les coups ça marche
[Musique]